hello everyone and welcome back to day
two of the semi-final match of the
Endora Savi rapid challenge between
Hikaru Nakamura and the Magnus Carlsen
yesterday was a pretty tough day for
Hikaru he lost the match with a result
of 3 to 0 so the for game wasn't even
played but now he will get his chance to
bounce back if he wins today then
tomorrow we get a third match so he Carl
with the white pieces but before two
very short announcements who made
another chest song it's this time it's
about maxi Marshall de Graaff so if
you're interested in checking out do
check it out it will be the first thing
you see in the description below and
also today we have our two tournaments
the Friday arena in the middle arena so
the links to those tournaments will also
be in the description below
dudu joined and as usual I'm gonna be
streaming them and showcasing your games
now getting back to the game it's really
really an interesting game and it's
really remarkable how many interesting
games are just you know coming out of
the Berlin defense these days yeah so
yesterday Magnus was able to win a game
with the Berlin defense and uh well yeah
he he feels very confident playing it
today against Hikaru so II 45 night of
three nights the c6 and brush up to b5
the rule opus is again on the board with
Knight to f6 Berlin defence and the d3
now with Bishop to c5 everything the
same characters characters as yesterday
and here he Carl goes for castles before
Knight B to d2 and Magnus still just
goes for Bishop to g4 which is kinda
usually not played as white can
immediately tackle that Bishop with h3
but this is what the Magnus prepared for
today's so better up to age 5 and now g4
and we reach the position from the
thumbnail where Magnus does not go back
with the bishop with Bishop to g6
instead he gives it up gives back gives
up the night for two pawns so Knight
captures we have eight chapters and
Bishop character so here Carson gave up
a knight for two points and also he has
a lot of pressure he has an excellent
Bishop here at this Bishop is pinning
the night putting pressure on the Queen
so I will see what what he can come up
with so first Bishop to e3 he's up a
piece so of course he car wants the
further trade pieces and Magnus declines
and now there is a game
well there are several games actually
where Bishop to d6 was played this
position has been reached before one
most notable one is a Peter like who
against now in Navarre that ended in a
draw after Bishop to d6 and also ye had
a one game against you
we're also Bishop to d6 was played but
here Magnus goes Bishop to e7 and it is
a new move so already as a move 10 we
have a completely new game now it's a
bit of a bit of a different idea than
going Bishop to d6 since you will have
the D file open for your Queen and also
there are some other world different
ideas so here we have Kings the h1 by
Hikaru pretty much the same idea that
was used by Navarro were by Peter like
when Navarro played Bishop to d6 against
him but now it's it kind of is different
Magnus goes f5 immediately now the point
is if this is ever captured then you
will have well you will have ideas like
efore will be possible and stuff like
that
so look the g1 this is the the idea
behind the whites defense we want to
play King H 1 work 2 G 1 and at some
point maybe even give up the rook for
the bishop here since you are already up
material you don't mind giving up the
exchange so Magnus goes h5 of course now
he doesn't mind capture since he would
also open up at the age file for his
rook to use for attack and the night the
sea 3 by Hikaru developing and now f4
that Magnus really making it hard for
for he car to develop his pieces the
show back to b2 and now even g5 so at
some point the Magnus can just capture
for example I have 3 and then continue
g4 and pull those pawns in in front of
the King and here he carves pieces are
not ideally placed the knight cannot
move this should not be doing all that
much rook also Queen not not doing much
so here Hikaru goes back Knight to be
one and it is often said that the
hardest move to find is with the knight
back so here he car wants to shift the
bishop over to this diagonal and then
develop the knight via the d2 square
maybe to c4 put pressure on e5 and so on
and here Magnus can choose between
something like Bishop to c5 which was
played in the game you can to try and
developing the Queen if you want to
Castle queenside or even
go for something like captors captors in
the g4 now which is a possibility but
Magnus says this is one of those cases
where the threat is stronger than the
execution
so he goes Bishop to c5 puts pressure on
the f2 pawn and Nakamura pretty much
instantly goes Bishop the c3 saying I
don't care about this I have to develop
my pieces so Bishop captures an f2 by
Magnus and now well you could go for the
pawn here let's say Bishop G actress
Hikaru already has material what he
doesn't have is development so here by
grabbing that pawn on e5 you don't
really gain all that much if rook g2 you
can even go Bishop to g3 and Magnus will
be very happy here
nakamura still wouldn't have all that
much to do with his pieces so after
Bishop captures on f2 we have Knight B
to d2 by Nakamura saying
grab that rook III really don't care and
now Magnus again can choose the capture
pulls g4 and so on but he still says no
it's still way too early for that so
just Queen to e7
he continues development and Nakamura
now goes Queen to f1 saying okay now you
either move the bishop or you capture it
a capture of my rook and here Magnus
captures so Bishop captures and g1 and
Queen captures and now not only did the
Queen unpin but also you are preventing
black from castling as the a7 point
would be hanging so that's a bit of a
problem if Carson can Castle queenside
bring the rook let's say over here start
pushing those points it should be there
should be a win for black but now Magnus
has to decide how to continue there
there is no queenside castle because of
Queen captures this end the e5 pawn will
fall
so here Magnus decides that it's now
time to do something so Bishop
characters on f3 Knight characters and
now of course g4
we have Knight captures on e5 and now
comes Luke the g8 we have rook to f1
finally all of his pieces are now
developed and now Magnus again has to
decide what to do still castling is
off-limits because this pawn falls if
you play f3 than just the Knight
captures that or even the rook you you
will not be able to recapture because of
Queen captures rook here so Queen to g5
now mag making f3 a possibility also now
you put some pressure on the night but
Hikaru immediately goes in in for
to attack with Queen 2d for now the
threat of course is Queen d7 check
followed by Queen to f7 checkmate and
Magnus has to find a way how to how to
prevent this he goes Queen to h4 with
check Hikaru says okay
I came to g1 I don't really have much to
do here and now Queen to g3 with check
and now a Magnus has to decide how to go
about this whether whether he wants a
perpetual here and take a draw or he
wants to perhaps try something else so
here he called repeats king h1 and
Magnus repeats Queen to h3 and
interesting an interesting idea if if
it's possible this rook to b8 you kick
away the the White Queen and then maybe
you will have some some attacking
chances just so you stop Queen sorry
Queen d7 fall by Queen to f7 checkmate
so rook the d8 is an idea but Magnus
just repeats Quinta h3 check King to g1
and now again you could go for some like
rook to d8 but Magnus now instead of
this goes to g3 g3 with the idea that he
wants the checkmate Nakamura with Queen
to h2 but also he guards the d7 square
with the Queen there is no Queen to d7
check now so Hikaru has to go back
Knight to f3 guarding the HDS were so
there is no checkmate
and now Magnus goes for G too
threatening the rook also Queen to h1
will now be an idea and he call just
plays rook to e1 and here Magnus has to
decide what to do and it's not an easy
decision to make he's a very long time
he's he has some 30 seconds on the clock
where Hikaru has I believe over 8
minutes and here now if you go for some
like Queen to h1 King f2 and you don't
have a good continuation here whatever
you play
I just doesn't work sorry about that to
give me a second
oh sorry about that it was some delivery
I was waiting for
so after this King to have to move like
I said you don't really have a good
continuation here and well you still
have have to deal with Queen to e5 check
followed by all sorts of check that
follow which you don't really know if
you'll be able to handle so after rook
to e1 Magnus decides for Queen captures
on f3 but now it's well now it's a he
Cara's move and he he definitely makes
it count Queen to e5 with check so what
do you play here well there are really
no good moves here Magnus went King to
d8 but now Queen to f6 width check and
here you have to go back if you go King
to c8 and Queenie six check just picks
up the rook so that's no good so a
Magnus went King te 8 but now well there
are there are a lot of different ways
for you to to win this game but one is
particularly interesting so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
either of the moves either Queen to East
six check which connects with the rook
followed by Bishop to b4 if the King
goes of course to FA to the van rook or
the move Nakamura played in the game
which is Bishop to b4 right away a slow
move but a deadly one threatening Queen
to e7 checkmate and now you don't really
have a good good defense here
Magnus played c5 at maybe make some room
for the king but Bishop character son c
c5 the threat still remains with King to
d7 by Magnus but here Nakamura just
played Queen f7 check and it was in this
position on most 33 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned the game and Nakamura wins Game
one of their second semi-final match and
he's on a good path to winning the match
and forcing a third match so here you
resign because whatever you do let's say
you go King to d8 doesn't really help
you just lose the rook so now and once
you go back it's you're still gonna get
to checkmate Queen to d5 check you're
gonna get King b8 Queen e6 check like
taking d8 now comes Queen e7 check here
and
we'll be checkmate or if you try and go
down the board let's say Queen King to
see six then its Queen to d5 with check
King b5 and now a lot of different moves
win here but also a four is just
perfectly winning let's say captures now
we're gonna go Quincy for checking here
and the rook that a1 will now deliver
checkmate
so really wild game and it's just
incredible how every game when the
Berlin is played such you know such a
beautiful stuff can happen so I really
don't mind it's not like in the old days
before you know alpha zero and let's
just zero when they played the Berlin it
was like super super boring but now
every game where the Berlin is played
it's like super super interesting so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said to check out who
has song the first link in the
description below and do join the
tournaments a second and third link in
the description below I would also like
to thank new case
Patrick yogurt Ben Fabian Adam Decker
and the knockin film on for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check you in my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
Dylan Doris a be rapid challenge
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day